[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pour un nouvel entretien
politique après david lisnard eric
zemmour qui avait succédé à jean luc
mélenchon général de villiers à marion
maréchal c'est au tour d'anne à ce quasi
bhl candidat déclaré à l'élection
présidentielle merci d'avoir accepté mon
invitation de connaissez le principe on
va parler politique ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de comprendre pourquoi vous dites
ce que vous dites pourquoi vous faites
ce que vous faites mais commençons par
vous présenter vous êtes cheminots
délégué syndical de sud rail c'est
pendant les grèves de 2018 que vous êtes
devenue une figure médiatique comme on
dit aujourd'hui vous avez même intégré
l'équipe des grandes gueules sur rmc
pendant deux ans également membre du npa
le nouveau parti anticapitaliste vous
faisiez partie du courant communiste
révolutionnaire baptisée révolution
permanente vous avez fait scission en
juillet 2021 vous êtes partis avec
quelques centaines de militants pourquoi
pourquoi l'extrême gauche at elle
toujours la tentation du groupuscule des
kia 2000 à berthe adhérents up ya
scission qu'est ce qui motive est celle
ci qu'est ce qui distingue aujourd'hui
révolution permanente vous avez conservé
le nom du nouveau parti anticapitaliste
de lutte ouvrière du cope parti
communiste français ou même de la france
a soumis la presse je ne sais pas si la
france insoumise se qualifier à
l'extrême gauche cheikh dans les médians
les qualifiés souvent à l'extrême gauche
moi je plus nuancé je considère que ça
ils pensent que c'est la vraie gauche
moi je considère que c'est un parti
réformiste en fait il cherche pas une
rive est une révolution même s'il
souhaite changer changer certaines
choses non pourquoi l'extrême gauche est
pourquoi le npa cette attitude on fait
tout simplement parce que
moi j'ai porté ma candidature avec les
camarades de ma tendance révolution
permanente à l'époque en interne
pour tous ne voulais pas y aller il ne
puis on voit quand il est interviewé ne
veut pas y aller il n'a pas envie il a
expliqué déjà plusieurs fois sauf que le
problème c'est que ben les batailles de
chapelle on va dire pour garder les
mains sur sur l'appareil fait qu'on a
contraint philippe poutou à rempiler
pour une troisième fois c'était même eux
qui arrêtait pas de dire c'étaient deux
candidatures maximum et puis finalement
on a expliqué il explique de cette
manière là que ce qui fait qu'ils ont
décidé de demander à philippe poutou de
faire une nouvelle candidature c'était
par crainte des parrainages la réalité
c'est que je crois qu'il ya une
quinzaine de parrainage qui nous sépare
comme quoi et sauf que nous on n'a pas
la tradition de la lcr de krivine de
besancenot de philippe couteau on part
d'une feuille totalement même pas
blanche comme jeudi mais une feuille
transparente parce qu'on n'a pas de
maire qu'il fallait aller revoir qui
nous ont parrainé ya cinq ans et au
final on est à plus de 150 parrainage
aujourd'hui et je crois en eux ils sont
autour d'eux des 170 d'après les
derniers calculs qu'ils ont fait donc
comme quoi si on avait mis la force de
l'appareil du npa plus notre force à
nous je pense qu'aujourd'hui on serait
même au delà du nombre de parrainages
que cas philippe routeau quoi donc donc
voila moi je le déplore je suis pas pour
la j'aime pas la division de manière
générale on n'aime pas la division
préfère être unis on préfère lutter
ensemble on a beaucoup de similarités
dans le programme dans nos prix avec
lutte ouvrière il convient avec les
poudrières aussi mais mois avant que je
n ai même pas elle-même parce que
c'était le npa non plus donc je suis pas
venu à adhérer au npa moi je suis pas
venu pour le npa je suis venu parce que
des camarades de révolution permanente
m'ont convaincu
en 2016 au moment de la loi elle
conneries de cette logique du marxisme
de cette logique du 3 2 6 mhz moi je dis
souvent pour déconner c'est la première
fois que les camarades sont venus me
dire nous on est trop de ski je leur ai
dit cassez-vous de la enfin moi je veux
rien savoir avec vos histoires de goulag
de machin etc parce que pour moi jeune
de 34 ans la fois où j'ai entendu parler
de trotski la première et dernière fois
que j'en ai pas j'en ai entendu parler
c'est pour le projet le brevet des
collèges quoi c'est une demi page dans
les livres de fernand nathan où il ya
écrit staline trotsky lénine les goulags
et cetera hitler machin et du coup on a
une vision sanguinaire en fait alors que
le marxisme léninisme trotsky et caetera
et riche en fait de deux lectures des
situations et 2016 c'est aussi mon
analyse de ce qui a été
la social démocratie moi j'ai voté
hollande en 2012 sa seule fois où
j'avais voté dans ma vie au deuxième
tour je me suis dit bon le changement
c'est maintenant mon ennemi c'est la
finance etc je me suis bon anna ça
mérite quand même que tu te déplaces
mettre un bulletin plus sarkozy le jeune
que j'étais à 18 ans qui a connu la mort
de zyed et bouna était très impacté par
parce qu'a été le sarkozy et son
quinquennat je me suis dit bon je vais
voter hollande parce que pour moi c'est
ça la gauche c'est ça toujours été le
parti socialiste je suis né à sarcelles
mon maire c'était dominique strauss kahn
je dis souvent il venait faire des
jongles avec nous à la sortie de l'école
pour
faire en sorte qu' on puisse on demande
à nos parents d'aller voter pour lui à
la mairie de sarcelles et dans ma
lecture ça a toujours été ça la gauche
était le ps et avec beaucoup aussi de
d'illusions sur les directions
syndicales et vous comprenez quand je
suis arrivé en 2016 que je comprends pas
pourquoi il ya un parti au pouvoir qui
s'appelle parti socialiste qui met en
place une loi comme la loi comme riz
avec le 49-3 qui auparavant essayé la
déchéance de nationalité et les
polémiques sur le sur le burqini et que
j'ai en face de moi philippe martinet je
me rappelle toute ma vie place de la
république à nuits de goût qui dit j'ai
pas le bouton pour la grève générale est
comme moi je suis déjà plus de 30 jours
de grève reconductible à un moment donné
je me dis c'est quoi mon avenir moi qui
ai deux enfants en fait et qui
considèrent que ce que j'ai en face de
moi ces 107 me représenter et quand j'ai
ses camarades là qui viennent et qui me
donne un texte de trotski sur les grèves
de 36 où il a écrit une phrase ou qu'ils
disaient la cgt n'a que la lance à
incendie pour appeler à la grève elle ne
fait que dire chut chut aux ouvriers
plutôt que les appeler en fait à aller
plus loin eh ben je me suis dit merde ce
gala dont je ne connaissais l'existence
que à l'époque de troisième j'ai
l'impression qu'il est derrière moi dans
la manifestation il a la même les et
c'est la première fois que j'entends
parler de bourgeoisie de bureaucratie
syndicale d'antagonisme de classe je
commence à identifier en fait que moi à
l'époque je pouvais dire élites
oligarchiques hommes peuvent dire
certains gilet jaune et certains gens
aujourd'hui d'en bas qui font leur
première expérience et je me dis merde
en fait moi je pensais que j'étais
français je pensais que c'était la
citoyenneté je pensais que j'avais des
intérêts communs avec bernard arnault
avec dry & company et tous les
milliardaires français je pensais que on
était pareil en fait on étaient égaux en
droit et c est au final bas le marxisme
a un peu sauvé je me suis dit mais en
vérité je comprends en fait pourquoi il
ya tout ça pourquoi il ya des lois qui
font en sorte que ben les classes
populaires souffrent autant qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui ça les arrange bien aussi
qu'on s'abstienne ça les arrange bien
que les classes populaires en fait se
désintéresse aussi
des élections et qu'au final il ya des
mouvements spontanés qui émergent et qui
commence à les inquiéter et puis aussi
dans cette présidentielle je peux venir
pour être aussi
modestement une boussole en fait de
classe à toutes ses classes populaires
comme moi je dis dans les meetings
redonné espoir aux gens qui ont perdu
espoir en fait perdu espoir dans cette
vie dans l'avenir et perdu espoir dans
la capacité en fait de faire de la
politique et de leur dire que je
m'appelle anas kazim je suis cheminot
j'ai 34 ans j'ai pas fait des grandes
études j'ai pas fait l'ena j'ai pas des
grands milliardaires derrière moi je
fais des fautes de français je fais des
fautes de grammaire mais qu'on est
capable de mettre à l'amendé ministre de
mettre à l'amendé députés en face à face
sur leurs propres projets de leur
démontrer et je pense que vous l'avez
dit à l'heure en deux notamment
2018-2020 la réforme de le voir céder
moment où justement je pense que j'ai
participé aussi à une forme à une forme
de fierté un peu ouvrir de se dire on
est ouvrier on est capable mais aussi de
de faire de la politique on est capable
de faire ça et si ma candidature au
moins elle peut servir à ça donc ce qui
vous distingue on pourrait dire dans
cette élection si vous allez jusqu'au
bout si vous avez les parrainages c'est
que vous êtes un ouvrier vous êtes
révolutionnaire mais vous êtes aussi un
descendant de l'immigration
postcoloniale moi je dis souvent moi je
suis petit fils de tirailleurs marocains
qui a fait la seconde guerre mondiale
mon grand père mon père il est venu en
tant que travailleur marocain en fait il
a travaillé chez simca à l'époque et
puis après
qui est devenu chrysler et puis il est
resté quelques années chez simca et puis
il est rentré au chemin de fer il a fait
passer partie du procès des travailleurs
marocains les fameux chibani comme on
les a appelés qui ont condamné la sncf
pour discrimination raciale et c'est
parce que pendant 40 ans de carrière il
n'avait pas les mêmes droits alors que
sur leur contrat de travail avait écrit
qu'ils avaient le droit aux mêmes aux
mêmes conditions de travail et de
salaire que les ouvriers français et
puis ben ils ont ils ont sacrifié leur
vie
passé des nuits entières sur les
chantiers et puis au final ils se sont
battus là dessus et puis oui je suis je
suis
issus de l'immigration faire et je pense
que lorsqu'il ya des dés et moore
aujourd'hui lorsque il ya il ya des
discours de plus en plus réactionnaires
lorsqu'on regarde la primaire de la
droite où moi je dis c'est la surenchère
de la xénophobie il y en a un qui est
pour 20000 places de prisons lotis les
pour 30000 le filet pour un guantanamo
1 il est pour eux reposent rejeté
l'ensemble des immigrés des possibles tu
dis dès qu'il ya une condamnation ces
retours au pays et qu'on voit en fait
tout ça on se dit mince et c'est assez
incroyable et je pense qu'il n'y a rien
de plus subversif que dans cette
présidentielle dans un des pays les plus
puissants et un pays qui a une histoire
impérialistes la france à l'échelle
internationale ça veut dire quelque
chose quand vous allez en palestine
quand vous allez au ans en syrie au
liban peu importe vous allez notamment
dans le moyen-orient et le maghreb la
france ça veut dire quelque chose et moi
j'ai un une fois j'ai échangé avec un un
camarade algérien il ya au mois d'août
et madiana si tu te rends pas compte en
fait de ce que ça veut dire pour nous
algériens mais pour tous les autres de
se dire que demain peut-être y aura un
ouvrier issus de l'immigration qui a la
même gueule que nous et qui va venir
dénoncer en fait l'histoire coloniale de
la france face à macro face à le pen et
caetera et je pense que l'extrême droite
le sait mieux que nous et c'est pour ça
que notamment extrême droite m'attaque
m'attaque beaucoup depuis depuis le
début parce qu'ils ne veulent pas de ça
ils veulent pas qu'un quinquin qu'un
jeune comme moi issus de l'immigration
maghrébine puisse être là et puis ce
leur contester le aussi la parole
politique et la lecture de d2 de la
situation la lecture de l'histoire
reviendra là dessus sur le côté des
colonials de votre candidature mais
d'abord sur l'ouvrier révolutionnaire le
marxiste
vous êtes prêtre la dictature du
prolétariat moi je suis pour la
dictature du prolétariat mais dans son
sens le plus simple comme moi je dis ça
fais moi la première fois ça m'a fait
peur aussi quand j'ai dit oh la la c'est
quoi ces histoires de dictature du
prolétariat et puis bah quand on apprend
et qu'on lit on comprend que c'est ni
plus ni moins qu'une démocratie ouvrière
au seul coup une dictature oui où
outre considérée aujourd'hui par exemple
on dira jamais qu'on est dans une
dictature du système capitaliste mais de
la même manière on pourrait le dire
c'est à dire que l'ensemble des
institutions et l'ensemble du pouvoir
est régi par une classe bourgeoise en
fait qui domine l'ensemble des
institutions et il n'y a pas de pays
aujourd'hui on peut s'entendre sur le
fait qu'aucun pays qu'ils soient sous
contrôle ouvrier en fait tous les moyens
de production sont entre les mains de
deux des classes populaires en général
quand on instaure la dictature du
prolétariat ce sont les intellectuels et
les membres du parti qui en héritent
c'est rarement les ouvriers bas et dans
dans l'histoire il ya eu
il ya eu peu il ya eu la dictature du
prolétariat au moment
la révolution d'octobre 1917 après après
moi mon problème n'est pas les
intellectuels en vrai moi je respecte et
je pense qu'on a besoin aussi
d'intellectuels comme on a besoin
d'ingénieurs de fonctionnaires est haute
mais de savoir vers qui mettent leurs
intérêts c'est un peu ce à quoi le
prolétariat à vos yeux à une vertu que
n'aurait pas les classes moyennes où la
bourgeoisie
l'averse je sais pas si c'est uniquement
une question de vertu mais je pense que
c'est une question stratégique avant
tout c'est à dire que je considère que
la classe ouvrière aujourd'hui elle a
entre les mains la possibilité par le
nombre et par l'implantation où elle est
au coeur en fête de la machine
capitaliste la possibilité en fait de
retourner les choses c'est à dire que
tout comme disait marx l'histoire
contemporaine et que l'histoire de la
lutte de classe et j'en suis
profondément convaincu quand je vois ne
serait-ce qu'en france sur le siècle qui
vient de s'écouler en fait tous les
moments d'avancées politiques ou de
recul sont liées à des moments de lutte
de classe soir lorsque la classe
ouvrière a été forte soit lorsqu'elle a
été réprimée par la violence et le sang
et elle a perdu derrière et à tout
niveau en fait je considère que oui la
classe ouvrière est la seule à même à
pouvoir porter un processus
allant jusqu'au bout lénine disait aussi
s'est il ya deux classes qui peuvent
faire la révolution c'est soit la
bourgeoisie on a vu l'exemple par
exemple en 1789 et dans d'autres
processus où le prolétariat avec
l'exemple de 1917 et que la classe
moyenne elle joue un rôle central il n'y
a pas de révolution sans classe moyenne
sauf que la classe moyenne ldl fait elle
défait les révolutions en fonction de
comment elle est le trotski disait cette
phrase magnifique il disait au moment de
vous y présenter dans un livre
magnifique s'appelle où va la france il
pressentait l'arrivée 2 du fascisme et
de pétain il disait attention parce que
la classe moyenne elle est comme le
malade de la grippe elle peut se pencher
du côté gauche comme du côté droit c'est
à dire qu'elle suit pour dire de la
manière la plus simple elle suit la
force c'est à dire que si elle considère
que dans les mains du prolétariat il y a
la possibilité en fait de défendre ses
intérêts et d'aller chercher quelque
chose de fort elle suivra le camp de la
classe ouvrir mais si elle considère que
le camp du prolétariat est en train de
la balade et est en train de se
de sa gueule pour dire de cette manière
là elle va elle va à l'extrême droite il
ya qu'à voir le front populaire en 36 en
france le front populaire espagnol où
vous avez des agriculteurs et des
paysans espagnol qui disait au front
populaire vous nous avez promis les
réformes agraires vous nous avez promis
de nous donner les terres ça fait huit
ans qu'on est on est avec vous dans le
processus révolutionnaire on ne voit
toujours rien du tout en fait et c'était
de la même manière pour salvatore
allende en 73 ans chili où il y avait
des corps donne industrielle où il y
avait des ouvriers qui faisait tenir la
balle à la baraque 24 24 pour que le
chili ne baisse pas face à
l'oppression de la cia et des patrons
les gens oublient la cia sait même pas
complotisme même panier d'or complot
c'est vraiment historique la cia
financer les patrons chiliens pour
mettre en grève les entreprises pour
empêcher qu'on puisse se dire une seule
seconde il est possible de mettre un
état socialiste en fait là bas au chili
et au final eh ben les ouvriers quand
ils ont vu que le dialogue le réformisme
etc n'était pas possible et bien un
moment donné lorsqu'il ya un putsch on
se retrouve décimée et puis derrière
c'est celui qui a été le général de
salvator allende kilinochchi qui a pris
qui a pris le pouvoir et ses terribles
en fait on doit apprendre de l'histoire
c'est sinon les condamné à la revivre
comme on parle encore de la classe
ouvrière m'ont fait y'a moins d'ouvriers
aujourd'hui qu'il y en avait auparavant
enfin autre fois c'est qu'il prend
l'intérieur pour vous aujourd'hui non
moi je vis sont ces travailleurs que que
vous
souhaiteriez le gouvernement déjà compte
déjà qu'on se dise quelque chose oui de
faire on n'est plus dans la l'époque
post industrielle en fait tous où le
prolétaire il avait dû camp bouyer sur
les joues même si on a encore beaucoup
aujourd'hui encore dans la métallurgie
dans dans les usines et autres mais moi
je dirais simplement que c'est la classe
ouvrière au sens large c'est-à-dire
celle celle qui pour dire de la manière
la plus simple à que la force de de ses
bras pour pouvoir vivre quoi si c'est à
dire qu'elle n'est elle n'est part
entière elle n'hérite de rien du tout
c'est à dire le jour où elle arrête de
travailler que qu'elle un accident du
travail qu'elle retrouve handicapé ou
autre si elle n'a pas quelques aides ou
un peu de famille pour eux pour
l'épauler elle n'a elle ne vit de rien
du tout pour moi c'est ça le prolétariat
ça c'est ce sont des aides soignantes ce
sont des cheminots ce sont des agents de
la ratp mais ce sont aussi des
professeurs de l'éducation nationale qui
qui certains ont fait des départs fois
cinq années d'études et et qui se
retrouvent à gagner 1600 1700 euros
c'est toutes celles et ceux qui
vive du fruit de leur travail s'ils se
réveillent pas le matin s'ils vont pas
gagner leur croûte en fait s'ils vont
pas faire en sorte de remplir leur frigo
ils vivent de rien et pour moi la classe
ouvrir c'est celle-là ccc dans le sens
le plus large dans cette définition il
ya beaucoup de gens qui rentrent sains
tous les gens qui vivent de leurs
salaires c'est mon cas oui oui pense pas
que vous allez pas accepter dans la
classe ouvrière et après j'ai iap iap
iap à ya pas de ya pas de limite mais
par exemple admettons si vous demain
vous vous décidez de mettre votre votre
votre énergie votre savoir vos
connaissances et votre positionnement au
service de la classe souvent quand on
regardait une gueule sous trotsky ou
d'autres enfin ils n'ont pas étés
c'était pas des prolétaires dans le sang
vient trop les airs d'honneur mais ils
ont mis ils ont mis de l'énergie en fait
à se dire que nous on a envie de se
servir de notre position pour faire en
sorte que ça soit celles et ceux les
exploités et les opprimés qui
réussissent comment expliquez-vous
anaska zibe que en dépit des inégalités
je sais pas chez elles sont plus
criantes qu'autrefois à mon avis non
mais en tout cas on y est plus sensible
on va dire en dépit de ces inégalités
la l'extrême gauche ne n'a pas l'air de
de l'emporter dans l'est dans les
esprits on parle de droitisation voire
d'extrême droite isation de la société
on parle pas de gauchisation ou
d'extrême gauche isation moi je suis
déchiré en désaccord avec ceux avec
cette analyse je considère qu' il ya une
droitisation que je pourrais qualifier
de super structurel c'est à dire au
niveau de la parole politique de la
parole médiatique ça je pense qu'on peut
tous accordé juste à regarder la gueule
des médias de plus en plus une chaîne
comme ces news qui pour moi est la
pointe avancée de ce discours
réactionnaire derrière bolloré ce qu'il
a fait à europe 1 avec presque 300
journalistes qui ont dû quitter le
navire en fait pour mettre à la place
des sonia mabrouk des coq et cetera chez
à l'europe où j'étais avant je suis tout
je vous ai toujours vous mêmes ce que
vous m'aimez génocidaire mais bon
l'émission n'a pas changé c'est vrai
mais vous n'êtes dernier des mohicans
la réalité c'est que dans dans les
médias et dans la parole politique il ya
une droitisation et ça vient même pas
spécialement que de l'extrême droite
quand vous avez arnaud montebourg moi je
considère pas qu'arnaud montebourg est
un est un fou ou qu'il a un moment donné
il a eu un moment d'absence je pense que
c'est calculé lorsqu'il le fait sa
sortie sur les transferts d'argent vers
les pays qui acceptent pas de récupérer
les immigrés en occuper âge je considère
qu'ils cessent qui fait lorsque roussel
va manifester avec zemmour bardella
philippot et c'est
avec les policiers avec les syndicats de
policiers mais tout en sachant ce qui
fait je considère que lorsqu'il a fait
une sortie en disant que ceux qui n'ont
pas vocation à rester légalement sur le
territoire doivent repartir chez eux
c'est aussi et c'est assez terrible donc
je pense que il ya une droitisation à
tous niveaux mais je considère cependant
qu'il ya une gauchisation si je peux
dire de cette manière là de la société
des idées qui est assez incroyable en
fait parce qu'on se droitise ray
vis-à-vis de l'immigration mais on
on serait on se gauchise ray en 3 6 le
plan social non droitise on droitise au
niveau politique sur tous les aspects
mais pour moi il ya quand vous prenez ne
serait-ce que les cinq années qui
viennent de s'écouler enfin un moment
donné on parlait de macron comme d'un
thatcher à la française d'un cécile
cornudet disait dans les colonnes des
échos elle disait au début c'est un
bulldozer on parlait de lui comme
jupiter un moment donné jupiter il a eu
quand même une grosse pierre qui a
commencé dans dans la chaussure qui a
été la sphère benalla ensuite
s'enchaîner avec avec le le mouvement
des gilet jaune vous avez eu des
mouvements importants autour du climat
de l'écologie les mouvements autour de
blake lively matters à l'appel du comité
justice et vérité pour adama la réforme
de le voir le système par points qui a
mis après des années d année enfin c'est
la grève la plus longue de l'histoire de
france quand même c'est à dire que si on
peut au moins remercier macron dans ce
quinquennat là c'est de nous avoir mis
le mouvement le plus subversif de
l'histoire de la vème république avec le
mouvement des jeunes voient souvent je
rappelle aux gens dans les meetings que
le 8 décembre on apprend qu'un
hélicoptère qui est dans la cour de
l'elysée craig filtrer emmanuel macron
que les renseignements généraux avait vu
dans les groupes facebook des gilet
jaune des plans d'évacuation des égouts
vous imaginez le niveau de d'inquiétude
de la bourgeoisie pour penser que des
hommes et des femmes 1 1 avec un gilet
jaune allait passer par les égouts de
l'elysée et on apprend que du coup
brigitte macron fait nettoyer le pc
jupiter le bunker de l'elysée et on met
deux mille cinq cents gendarmes et crs
un moment donné si ça ce n'est pas de la
peur en fait du pouvoir je sais pas ce
que c'est et derrière on met un million
et demi de personnes le 5 décembre
contre la réforme la réforme de le voit
donc cette nouvelle génération elle est
là sauf que elle ne s'incarne dans
aucune et là je suis entièrement
d'accord donc une force politique
institutionnelle parce que pour moi
quand je parle de la gauche
institutionnelle ce n'est pas uniquement
les partis c'est pas europe écologie les
verts et la france est soumise aux c'est
aussi les directions syndicales parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand on voit l'ensemble
des mouvements qui émergent ce sont des
mouvements qui viennent d'en bas ce sont
des mouvements spontanés de la base qui
échappe totalement au contrôle au
contrôle des kindle sont dans aucun
parti d'après ce que vous avez ouais
dont on ne connaît pas les intentions de
vote et on ne sait même pas s'il vote
qui ne sont pas dans les syndicats tels
qu'on les connaît et donc ça veut dire
que effectivement ils ont probablement
un certain poids mais où
si on parle de poids est ce qu'on parle
dont le problème c'est que je pense
qu'on a souvent tendance à parler de
poids uniquement électorale et je pense
que c'est une erreur en fait de
considérer que le seul rapport de forces
est la seule force politique ne peut
être qu'une force politique
institutionnelle c'est soit ce mouvement
qui a existé ce qu'on disait notamment
avec la france insoumis si vous vous
souvenez au moment des européennes
on a d abord vous regardez vous voyez
léger je ne sais pas des gens pour la
france insoumise ils n'ont pas voté pour
les gilet jaune mais ça va pas voter non
plus pour marine le pen par contre le
bloc bourgeois il s'est resserré autour
de macron il a dit il faut pas lâcher
lui il faut quand même donner des gages
à la république en marche cependant
quand vous avez des gens qu'un minimum
chante pour l'honneur des travailleurs
mois ci à bien des gens que je considère
qu'ils ne votent pas l'extrême droite et
qui sont pas en train de faire la chasse
à l'immigré et qui chante pour l'honneur
des travailleurs ça veut dire ça veut
dire quelque chose quand vous avez des
mouvements je disais au tour après la
mort de georges frêche vous avez plus de
cent mille personnes à l'appel du comité
à damas qui est un une famille de
victimes de violences policières s'est
pas échoué aux racismes ce n'est pas
mitterrand le parti socialiste et ses
les gros syndicat derrière qui appuient
c'est un groupe d'une dune ii d'une
famille de victimes de violences
policières qui arrive autour notamment
de la figure dassa traoré à trouver le
tempo juste pour mettre cent mille
personnes dans la rue à ce moment là et
notamment ces gens là ils se retrouvent
pas dans le système institutionnel
mais alors pourquoi vous vous présentez
vous voulez vous vous présenter à
l'élection présidentielle puisque c'est
pas là que ça se passe bajeux très
sincèrement enfin c et moi je dis ce
n'est pas suffisant certes le système
institutionnel n'est pas n'est pas
suffisant qu'on le veuille ou non moi
j'ai pas une lecture gauchistes en fait
de l'élection présidentielle je
considère que c'est un moment politique
important qu'on soit abstentionnistes
convoite blanc qu'on vote peu importe
pour lequel candidats c'est un moment
dans lequel les gens au l'arize toutes
les discussions politiques c'est un
moment qui permet aussi aux militants
révolutionnaires que je suis de pouvoir
aussi dialoguer plus largement que
simplement des logiques ouvriériste pour
le dire de cette manière là et c'est un
peu ce que le reproche que je peux faire
notamment à lutte ouvrière ou au npa
c'est d'avoir une logique très
ouvriériste en fait plus sur le côté de
l eau avec un peu une continuité avec ce
qu'a été le pc des années vous savez des
années 50 60 et c'est beaucoup ou par
exemple quand marianne va parler de ma
personne va dire nasca zipser le
marxiste qui s'acoquine avec les des
coloniaux parce que pour eux le marxisme
c'est le pour le dire de cette
manière-là le cégétiste qui luttent
contre la réforme des retraites le
cégétiste qui lutte contre l'oppression
faite à une femme qui porte le voile
c'est plus le marxisme c'est la coquine
mans avec les des coloniaux et donc je
considère que parfois on a tendance en
fait à avoir qu'une qu'une mono couleurs
en fait de discours le grand capital le
grand patronat etc et que moi je dis au
contraire le moment politique si le
moment on peut parler des droits de gbt
hisser moment on peut parler des
violences sexuelles et sexistes faites
aux femmes ces moments on peut parler
d'impérialisme mois dont dans mes
meetings je parle de ce qui se passe
actuellement avec avec halle 6 6 7
cette révélation de odyssée sur sur
l'egypte actuellement enfin c'est moi je
fais des grèves les gens me connaissent
à travers les grèves mais moi si je
viens vous voir dans une grève je vais
vous parler de d'auto-organisation je
vous parlais de 15 degrés je vais vous
parler de démocratie ouvrière mais si
vous vous êtes grévistes à la ratp je
vous dit frédéric taddeï regardez la
palestine ou ceci ou cela vous allez me
dire normalement mais on arrête de
m'emmerder ton histoire de deux de
violences sexuelles palestine là je suis
dans ma grève parle moi de comment je
fais pour gagner et du coup je considère
que les moments aussi de d'élections
présidentielles comme celle-là permet de
pouvoir balle et un certain nombre de
sujets en trois meetings on a rassemblé
presque 1300 personnes mais dans aucune
grève je suis capable en trois en trois
moments de parler à 1300 personnes de
deux sujets aussi vastes que l'écologie
que les violences sexistes que la
question de l'anti racisme anti
impérialisme etc etc je pense que c'est
une richesse et juste pour conclure là
dessus je considère que néanmoins ma
candidature même si elle est on va dire
elle ne cherche pas à considérer que
l'issue serait institutionnels et serait
à travers le fait de plier un papier le
mettre dans l'urne mais néanmoins si
modestement je peux te permettre de
donner une boussole politique dans la
période à celles et ceux qui ne savent
plus où donner de la tête considère que
c'est soit on se met en dehors et puis
on fait son petit boulot et puis on se
préoccupe de rien mais moi j'ai envie de
dire que c'est pas ça le l'issue finale
c'est nos luttes c'est tout ce qu'on a
fait est qu'au contraire essayer de
donner un peu plus de clarté à ce qui
est en train de se passer et aussi de
redonner de la fierté ouvrière à celles
et ceux qui luttent et de se dire que
peut-être que oui on peut on peut on
peut changer les choses si vous me
permettez juste une dernière phrase
dernière parce qu'il est une pause mais
à part dans notre dernière il falloir
vous dire que c'est même pas une
histoire de danas quasi bout de marque 6
il y avait un sondage atlantico qui a
été réalisé par ifop en avril 2019 au
moment de la au coeur du mouvement des
jeunes juste quelques semaines après la
fameuse scène du fouquet's 39% des
sondés des français sondés considéré
qu'il fallait une révolution dans le
pays pour pouvoir changer les choses
c'était 20 points de plus que nos
homologues allemands et les sociologues
canaliser sa 10è c'est un chiffre
incroyable en fait de considérer que les
40% des français qui considèrent que le
système institutionnel ne va plus en
fait et qu'il faudrait une révolution
dans le pays pour que les choses elle
chance et moi ça me donne du baume au
coeur aujourd'hui en tant que
révolutionnaires de se dire peut-être
dans cette élection présidentielle venir
avec ce discours là un discours
révolutionnaire déterminé à pouvoir
changer les choses on fait une pause on
se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
qu'elle ait fait le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron aura-t-il eu sur le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages français on
m'a toujours sous-évalué le rythme de
l'inflation et donc on peut vous chantez
lecteurs le pouvoir d'achat a augmenté
la réalité c'est qu'il abaissait le
pouvoir d'achat lui des 0 1% là sur
riesch a énormément augmenté est ce
qu'il faut pour avoir du pouvoir d'achat
partagé pour la programmation bien la
seule manière de faire c'est une
activité privée dynamique il permet de
distribuer des revenus suffisants pour
faire face au coût de la vie et la
réalité c'est que sur ce plan rien n'a
été fait vous faites de la dette comme
ça et quand vous imprimer des billets
comme ça vous fléchés de fait sur les
gens qui détiennent le capital
donc ça arrive de fait sur les marchés
par exemple l'action ça fait monter les
titres mais ça ne m'apporte rien dans
votre assiette
[Musique]
la hausse des prix du gaz et
d'électricité touchent directement au
moins 36 millions d'européens pour la
france plus question de fermer 14
réacteurs pourraient nuire à 50% la part
du nucléaire en 2035 l'allemagne est
dans une toute autre logique devenu club
by gaz russe en europe elle s'oppose à
la stratégie nucléaire de la france
mieux à est en crise tout cela c'est le
reflet en fait d'un conflit plus large
dont elle n'est que la proie est
aujourd'hui la victime
les français ont découvert une réalité
qu'il n'avait pas compris ou plutôt
qu'on ne leur avait pas expliqué
[Musique]
on l'a compris ades quasi bousetta
d'ouvriers à révolutionnaire marxiste
mais qui défend aussi le droit des
croyants à pratiquer leur religion c'est
plus le podium du peuple la religion
c'est l'opium du peuple enfin à prèsent
sur la définition elle et elle et elle
est différente moi je défends le fait
nous on est une organisation at et donc
c'est pas notre problème il n'est pas de
défendre une religion plus qu'une autre
ou quoi que ce soit mais il est dire
simplement que nous on participe à
l'oppression d'une catégorie en fait peu
importe que ce soit une liées à sa
pratique religieuse que ce soit son
genre son origine ou hot & co a eu à
aucun moment le marxisme a participé à
une forme d'oppression d'une catégorie
religieuse est souvent le l'opium du
peuple quand on lit c'est aussi lié
aussi à ce qu'a été l'église au moment
de marque c'est ce que pour éviter
derrière lettres l'islam dans d'autres
pays que le dos et dans d'autres pays
c'est vrai que sur certaines nuances
enfin moi par exemple je dénonce
notamment le rôle que peut avoir un pays
comme l'arabie saoudite le fait d'eux
des transactions des achats de raphaël
est haute pour bombarder pour bombarder
le yémen de ce que on disait juste avant
autour de la politique de al sisi qui
fait un putsch qui tue près de mille
opposants au moment de la prise du
pouvoir qui est décoré de la légion
d'honneur aujourd'hui et qui se sert des
renseignements de l'armée française pour
bombarder des contrebandiers on a trouvé
du tabac et du riz moi j'ai ce que vous
imaginez si par exemple vous frédéric
tanné pour vous prendre en exemple vous
traversiez la frontière de andorre avec
deux cartouches de clopes en plus et
avait un rafale qui viennent qu'au
dessus qui bombardé en plein milieu de
l'autoroute la voiture de frédéric
taddei et ça dérange personne on se
dirait cdc des partenaires qui
s'échangent des bons et loyaux services
non à un moment donné on doit aussi
avoir la clairvoyance de dénoncer
l'essai dans ces pays là parce que qu'on
le veuille ou non ils sont ils font
partie aussi de la classe dominante que
ça soit l'algérie aussi la religion
pouvoir
il ya des milliardaires algériens qui
ont essayé de de participer à la
répression à la répression populaire du
duel est donc le mois jeudi ni plus ni
moins que
le rôle aussi des révolutionnaires des
marxistes c'est aussi d'être aux côtés
des opprimés et lorsqu'on opprime une
catégorie et notamment je pense aux
femmes qui portent le voile dans ce pays
on essaie de leur faire porter tous les
maux de l'humanité soit disant derrière
une forme d'universalisme des lumières
etc etc etc on a toutes ces nouvelles
figures qui ont
qui sont racisées comme je dis qu'ils
servent aussi de faire valoir à tout un
discours réactionnaire c'est pas
spécialement l'extrême droite qui a
sorti l'islamo gauchisme c'est tout le
secteur autour notamment du printemps
républicain c'est lui qui est ultra
offensif le walkie sme c'est pas
bardella ou hulu zemmour qui en a parlé
le premier le walkie sme c'est ça vient
de la bouche des naulleau ça vient de la
bouche de tout cet cette pseudo gauche
qui se revendique un peu duval 6 mai
cetera comme avait dit valls il ya deux
gauches irréconciliables et à la gauche
qui
soutient l'islamo gauchisme et nous on
serait la vraie gauche et et ces gens-là
participent aussi à ce discours là
ultraréactionnaire notamment contre les
femmes qui portent le voile ce qui
c'était cette publicité là du conseil de
l'europe et première être 7000 vent
debout c'est tout le site où ce secteur
là en fait qui est qui qui arrive
frontalement et qui participe à user et
à détourner et comme je dis c'est
uniquement face aux femmes qui portent
le voile qui redécouvre le marxisme et
cette femme fameuse phrase de l'opium du
peuple par contre pour tout le reste ils
en ont rien à faire du 26 mai
puisque vous vous le dites vous même
vous vous sentez proche du mouvement des
colonials vouloir emprunter un certain
nombre d'idées vous vous considérez
comme un rat 6 et vous même penser qu'il
ya un racisme d'état
est-ce que moi plus que vous m'avez pris
en exemple koné - exemples inverses est
ce que vous voyez comme un blanc est-ce
que je vous vois comme un blanc vous
êtes blanc de fait j'ai pas besoin de
vous voir comme un blanc après le mont
problème n'est pas que vous soyez
blanc très sincèrement enfin moi je n'ai
pas jeu par exemple le concept qui peut
parfois être entendu de wight privilèges
etc moi je sais tu pas un concept que
kim qui me parlaient que j'utilise moi
je suis pour l'unité de ma classe ster
que je considère mes mails vous répondez
pas exactement vous savez bien ce qui se
passe quand vous parlez d'universalisme
c'est ce que revendique tout ce que vous
vous êtes dénoncé le plan théorique qui
voudraient fermer les yeux bondir de
cette manière même fermer les yeux quand
fait n'y aurait pas de racisme d'état il
y aurait autre chose c'est aussi ça
j'étais petit ma mère me disait on dit
pas les pays arabes ont dit les péchés
voilà y'a pas d'aram de par hab et ça
n'existe pas aujourd'hui ça semble très
tout à fait dépasser comme anti racisme
on finira au contraire si si si je suis
arabe toi tu es blanc etc etc
certains pensent qu'on n'y a perdu qu'au
fond il ya l'antiracisme d'hier nous
voulaient tous pareils l'antiracisme
d'aujourd'hui devrait donc vous vous
prévalez nous veut tous différents le
problème au fond c'est est-ce que c'est
vrai est-ce que effacer les ter - est-ce
que effacer de notre esprit ce qu'on
voudrait ne pas être du racisme
systémique est ce que ça c'est pourtant
vrai jamais les noirs et les arabes ont
été opprimés à votre époque quand vous
étiez jeunes que vous que qu'on dise
l'épicier arabe ou pas ça ne change pas
l'oppression que a vécu et que vivent
aujourd'hui encore les arabes et les
noirs c'est même pas des statistiques
d'un groupuscule de gauche ou je ne sais
quoi ces sont des statistiques de 2
d'organismes connu des états unis
d'angleterre et d'ailleurs et parfois
même de france sur comment il ya un
dernier sondage là qui était une enquête
énorme je crois c'est l'express où les
échos sur le l'embauchent avec avec un
nom maghrébin sur le cv etc qui montre
encore aujourd'hui en en 2021 que ben
lorsqu'on est noir ou arabe et ben pour
l' embauche c'est plus compliqué les
contrôles au faciès sont toujours
présents pour avoir un logement c'est
aussi la croix la bannière et qu'au
final cette catégorie sociale aussi elle
et elle est opprimé après moi je fais
pas spécialement qu une fixette sur le
terme de sur les termes qui peuvent être
utilisés je considère que oui un racisme
systémique et que c'est comment on
affronte comment on lutte mais est ce
que vous considérez parce que c'est
souvent ça qui fait peur aux blancs ce
qui l'est blanche avait il se considère
pas comme blanc il considère que tous
les autres sont différents mais eux ils
se voient pas comme un groupe et c'est
nouveau qu'on les regarde comme un
groupe alors ils ont du mal à s'y
habituer et échoue il s'inquiète très
souvent dix ans mais est ce qu'on va me
considérer comme comme porteur des
crimes qu'on pu commettre les blancs
parce que effectuant les blancs pas
toujours été exemplaire c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire surtout qu'ils avaient
du pouvoir est souvent plus de pouvoir
que les autres au cours des derniers
siècles donc ils n'ont pas toujours été
exemplaire est ce que on va se retrouver
de porter des crimes voit la catégorie 6
mois en je vouvoyais entendre la
rabelais je le disais il est porteur de
tous les crimes des arabes alors à la
fois il est il est le descendant des
victimes de la colonisation document il
va avoir de revendications en tant que
tel et merveilles va pas accepter que je
lui dise qu'il est aussi le descendant
des arabes qui ont colonisé l'espagne
pendant cette suspension
mais qu'on s'entende bien il ya du
racisme aussi et pas que chez les blancs
je pense que bouteflika
été profondément aussi raciste à sa
manière je pense qu'il ya plein d'autres
présidents et rois et autres qui sont
qui sont aussi profondément raciste et
peut-être
des prolétaires qui du fait des discours
réactionnaire insiste au quotidien
qu'ils entendent et parfois combinées
avec une certaine misère sociale quand
on n'arrête pas de dire que
salarié de bridget sloan que son
problème c'est pas le patron de
bridgestone qui a pris 3,8 millions de
cice mais que son problème c'est mamadou
à côté qui risque de lui piquer son
boulot je pense qu'à un moment donné
quand on est dans une misère sociale
profonde ses discours réactionnaire il
pénètre aussi la classe ouvrière n'est
pas imperméable à tous les discours n
est pas immaculée de 2,2 to de toutes
les meilleures choses il ya parfois des
choses qui pénètre aussi la classe
ouvrière comme on dit la pensée qui
domine c'est aussi la pensée de la
classe dominante a martelé ces discours
là mon problème il n'est pas celui de
jean-pierre de bridgestone c'est pas lui
qui est responsable du colonialisme ans
en fait en algérie au maroc en tunisie
c'est pas lui qui est responsable de ce
qui s'est passé de la traite négrière ou
autre mon problème il est ce système
depuis des années et des années et puis
ces grands hommes parfois qu'ils peuvent
est idéalisé par par eric zemmour que ça
soit bonaparte et c'est en faisant fi de
ce qu'a été la traite négrière de ce
qu'ont été les lois contre contre
notamment les juifs de ce qui a été tout
le passé colonial de la france de faire
parler de la grandeur de la france sans
jamais parler de d'où vient cette
puissance aussi économique qui qu'elle
pète et parfois même à gauche lorsque
j'entends quelqu'un comme mélenchon qui
va expliquer que la france ait deuxième
puissance maritime mondiale
moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour nos
pêcheurs que ça soit marseille en
bretagne ou ailleurs mais c'est pas les
côtes françaises de l'hexagone qui font
que la france est deuxième puissance
maritime mondiale faut faut qu'on puisse
le dire ça faut qu'on puisse dire grâce
à quoi la france que va chérir et ai
parlé eric zemmour de toute sa grandeur
de tout ce passé impérialiste sans dire
que c'est grâce à aux anciennes colonies
qu'aujourd'hui s'appelle aux territoires
d'outre-mer que la france arrive aussi
avec deuxième puissance maritime et il
faut qu'on puisse se dire ces choses là
et donc mon problème et cette catégorie
là elle est pas moi mes collègues je
lutte avec eux je lutte avec eux c'est à
dire jamais dit à toi attend toi tu es
blanc alors attends demain matin moi
déjà je lutte avec les noirs et les
arabes j'ai jamais fait aucun prix ni de
genre ni de religion ni de couleur ni
quoi que ce soit je considère qu'au
contraire malheureusement ces discours
et visa c'est aussi à nous diviser le
discours ambiant de droitisation il
vient il est pas anodin il n'est pas
anodin tout à l'heure je vous disais ce
fameux sondage d'atlantico mais quand
vous regardez le cevipof
quand vous regardez l'ensemble des
enquêtes de défiance vis-à-vis du
pouvoir un moment donné quand il reste
une des cartes c / en bas c'est un
moment donné se met aussi la zizanie moi
je cite ce
cette grève de bergame c'est une usine
qui a fermé dans le 91 et il ya un
reportage qui est passé dans c dans
l'air et un moment donné c'est l'annoncé
de la liquidation judiciaire ils disent
les syndicalistes sorte ils disent c'est
terminé ils ne veulent pas accepter de
repreneurs l'usiné va fermer il ya une
travailleuse blanche pour dire de cette
manière là est une travailleuse qui
portent le voile et les deux quand elle
parle ensemble la travailleuse blanc ce
n'est pas en train de dire ça à cause de
toi avec ton voile les deux elles disent
mais en fait c'est le système comme ça
qui est qui qui qui nous broie elle dit
est une elle dit c'est le système
capitaliste elle dit ça fait 40 ans 50
ans tous ces politiciens tous en fait
ils ont tout fait pour les patrons ils
ont rien fait pour nous et je trouve que
ces gens là ne sont pas marxiste non
plus peut-être aucun livre de l'histoire
révolutionnaire mais ils ont cette
lucidité et cette clarté en fait
politique à comprendre qui sont les
ennemis les gilet jaune pour beaucoup on
a dit c'est cette france périurbaines en
fait qu'ils étaient très éloignés de la
politique qui au demeurant mener sa vie
très tranquillement et quand vous
écoutez les gilet jaune vous voyez que
il visait quelqu'un est visé ils disent
l'oligarchie les élites etc mais
aujourd'hui mais il vise un terreau où
on a l'impression que tout le monde vit
ce quelqu'un c'est à dire que
que tu nommes me prendre en exemple
puisque en tant qu'homme et
hétérosexuels
français n'ayant pas eu la chance de
naître dans la classe ouvrière je me
sens le potentiel ennemis de plein de
gens de la lutte des classes je puis
peut être désigné comme l'ennemi est
responsable de l'exploitation anne
héritier de l'impérialisme de
l'impérialisme français que vous
dénoncez j'aurais pu bénéficier
même pas mais mes aïeux mais tout
simplement mois par le fameux privilège
blanc ou en tout cas en tant qu'héritier
d'un système c'est de ce fameux domaine
maritime mondial vous dites même on le
doit à cette époque là je peux être
aussi accusé d'être responsable du
patriarcat donc de la culture du vial
donc de l'homophobie je peux être
accusée aussi alors d'être responsable
évidemment de l'islamophobie et de
l'antisémitisme
et cetera et cetera et finalement je me
pose toujours la question on est
responsable de quoi puisque on va me
dire aussi que si si j'ai fait de bonnes
études c'est parce que j'avais un bagage
culturel que j'ai hérité et si j'ai fait
une carrière on me dira que c'est grâce
à mon réseau social donc en fait
responsable d' absolument rien de ce que
j'ai fait je vous rassure moi j'ai aucun
diplôme donc je sais vraiment un exemple
qui n'est immunisé pas le mien mais on
dira que je ne suis responsable de rien
de ce que j'ai fait que je suis
responsable de tout ce qu'ont fait les
autres
mais la question l est pas il faut
essayer de
de dépersonnaliser aussi les choses ils
sont que oui mais le problème il n'est
pas moi mon ennemi les salles c'est un
ennemi de classe et dans cette classe il
y à des catégories parfois qui vont au
plus réactionnaires comme peut être peut
être et moore aujourd'hui peut être
incarné à travers et moore mais mon
ennemi lénine disait une phrase
magnifique il disait notre seul ennemi
celui qui vit du travail d'autrui qui
vit du travail d'autrui c'est à dire
celui qui ne crée rien du tout mais qui
vit de l'exploitation des uns et des
autres après derrière que vous vous
soyez né et que votre pays dans lequel
vous êtes né bénéficier profite
aujourd'hui de de richesses et de choses
qui ont été accaparées dans l'histoire
le problème il est pour moi la limite il
pourrait se poser si vous vous en êtes
fier en fait c'est à dire que vous
revendiquez cette chose là par contre
vous pouvez avoir bénéficié de ces
choses là et de vous dire je trouve que
c'est pas normal je reconnais c'est
aussi qu'on peut être fier de son pays
pour nous tous taux d'erreur réseau et
tout le monde est celle que vous
incriminez m'aimait tout le monde tout
le monde est
dans n'importe quel pays a une fierté de
son pays les jamaïcains vous allez leur
demander vous dire je suis fier de la
jamaïque le belge il va dire je suis
faire du et au final qu'est ce qu'on
fait ça sert à quoi à quoi ça sert tout
cette fierté
incommensurable que chacun pour son pays
orwell disais cette phrase magnifique là
où il ya le patriotisme il ya la guerre
et moi je considère que comme le disait
au début je pensais que ma citoyenneté
mon lien direct il était avec bernard
arnault ou draghi ou peu importe mais
aujourd'hui je dis en tant que militant
révolutionnaire en tant que militant
international ce que mes intérêts
communs ils sont avec le prolétaire
polonais le prolétaire camerounais
sénégalais brésiliens etc et il n'est
pas en fait de ses cendres dans une dans
une patrie c'est ce qu'on reproche aussi
aux riches aujourd'hui on dit qu'ils ont
fait sécession qu'ils n'ont plus de
solidarité que l égard de leur propre
classe 10 éliminés au tour de la planète
vous les voyez comme ça aux maisons de
certitudes certitude quand on a des des
intérêts diamétralement opposées qu'ils
défendent la preuve en est que ça les
dérange pas de voyager partout dans le
monde on parle par exemple
on parle de libéralisme protectionniste
est un terme qu'utilisent notamment eric
zemmour c'est à dire en gros il faut du
protectionnisme façon trump et autres
mais bolloré qui soutient eric zemmour
dans sa candidature bolloré la plupart
de son chiffre d'affaires il le fait il
le fait à l'étranger donc il est où ce
patriotisme économique à la française et
ces croix l'important c'est de ces pays
c'est à pau ici là où je travaille à
palais mais il n'est jamais que vos
impôts si vous entreprise vous les
exploiter mais puisque je vais vous
donner l'exemple et nationale française
elles sont pas résidentes spécialement
français mais rompt les impôts par
rapport il ya gagné c'est plutôt content
d'en avoir en général donc pas vous mais
on fait moi je suis pas un anti travail
qu'on s'entende bien je considère que au
contraire moi je veux que les gens il
travaille je veux même partager le temps
de travail entre tous les bras
disponibles pour sortir justement pas
non plus anti entreprises en général les
ouvriers sont c'est pas je suis qu'est
ce qu'on entend et qu'est ce qu'on met
derrière entreprises si les entreprises
derrière ce terme là que peut utiliser
le patronat savoir que c'est un homme ou
une femme qui donne à manger à 1000
familles cinquante mille familles ou
autre comme parfois on peut entendre que
tel patron en fait il fait nourrir des
milliers de familles moi je dis non
c'est les ouvriers qui font mourir qui
nourrissent le patron lorsque vous avez
carlos ghosn qui pendant quasiment un an
et demi et disparaît de renault est-ce
que les usines renault arrêté de tourner
non elles ont eu leurs ingénieurs leurs
cadres leurs ouvriers cetera leur
manager de 2 sur les chaînes de montage
qui ont fait en sorte que renault
continue à produire on sait pas dire ah
mince il est le patron peut plus rien
faire par contre à linverse mettez tout
en taule tous les salariés et tous les
ouvriers de renault edit à carlos ghosn
bah tiens montre nos toits maintenant
qu'il fait une qui nourrit 10000 20000
famille montre nous toi comment tu fais
mais il est cas il est capable de rien
du tout et c'est une réalité en fait
c'est à dire comme on dit on à un patron
ils gagnent 17 millions d'euros par an
ça fait un an et demi il a disparu mais
il ya des voitures qui continue et à des
twingo est d'aider peugeot qui
continuent à être vendue à droite et à
gauche à en donner on doit se poser on
doit se poser les bonnes questions et
savoir quelles qu'elles sont nos ennemis
et oui de fait pour moi le
protectionnisme
économique est un leurre parce que quand
vous avez patrick pouyanné patron de
total qui réorganise et qu'il y ait fait
un plan social à la raffinerie de
grandpuits 700 emplois en moins qu'on
met des grands panneaux change même le
logo total énergie on met des publicités
avec des panneaux photovoltaïques et
concia battant c'est bien comme une
raffinerie de pétrole la transition
écologique toile gauchistes là tu es
quand même pas pour qu'on continue à
polluer et que derrière vous apprenez
que ce même patrick pouyanné il va raser
sur 1500 km un pipeline qui vient raser
les villages entiers en ouganda que ils
sont en train de chercher à exploiter le
gaz de schiste en dessous du désert
algérien de fracturer en fait notamment
toute la nappe phréatique algérienne
lorsque vous voyez ça vous dites mais
attendez ces îles où ce protectionnisme
économique en fait y'a pas de
protectionnisme économique parce que ces
entreprises là elles s'enrichissent et
souvent ça un deuxième ça un effet
inverse le protectionnisme économique
c'est que pour les autres pour soi on ne
veut pas demander aux vendeurs de
beaujolais de épinards dites-leur
battant tu comprends bien que l'on veut
plus personne ventes chez nous et efface
et on veut mettre la priorité nationale
à la vente tu comprends bien que le
chinois ou où le canadien il a le droit
aussi de faire la même chose donc du
coup ton pinard tu vas plus le vendre
par contre n'en va être content va dire
à regarder le vin français se vend super
bien en chine le parfum regarder lvmh
c'est une fierté le luxe français
s'exporte partout mais par contre toi le
pour dire vulgairement tu
rentrent pas chez nous tu rentres pas en
france et que moi je pense que c'est une
connerie en fait faut arrêter vraiment
s'il ya bien quelque chose qui pour moi
doireau doit nous aider à rompre avec
cette idée nationaliste protectionnisme
c'est bien déjà d'une part la crise
climatique à quoi servent les frontières
lorsque vous avez la tempête alex qui
vient ravagé le var lorsque vous avez
des plus de grêlons de la taille de
balles de golf quirky qui détruisent des
récoltes d'agriculteurs qui sont à la
gorge entre les huissiers et et le
changement climatique et la sécheresse à
quoi servent les les frontières lorsque
vous avez le coc vite 19 et le nouveau
variant qui arrive toujours de la même
manière du sud des pays qui ont été les
moins vacciner qui sont les moins
bien munis de manière sanitaires et qui
derrière nous mais dans cette situation
vous avez 50 mille cas en france
actuellement peut-être qu'on sera
confiné chez même pas d'ailleurs pour la
campagne présidentielle comment ça va se
passer comment ça se passe si demain on
est confiné et qu' on doit aller
chercher les parrainages on va toquer
chez qui on voit toqués où on fait
comment on sait pas tout ça donc il
faudrait qu'on puisse comprendre que les
frontières elles ont été bâties par les
hommes après des guerres après des
conquêtes est haute et qu'elle vise à
séparer à séparer les gens et moi je
pense que on devrait commencer à les
ouvrir et commencer à considérer que les
gens sont libres d'aller où ils veulent
parce que frédéric taddei anaska zip
demain s'ils décident de me remplir une
valise et d'aller dans n'importe quel
pays ce leur suffit juste d'un peu
d'argent d'aller sur le site de air
france et de se dire est ce que frédéric
tu as envie qu'on aille en thaïlande ou
au japon bon on va y aller ensemble on
ira ensemble et on va là on va arriver à
la douane on va passer notre valise à la
limite on simplement pour les vacances
pas plus mais déjà ne serait-ce que les
sont rentrés les gens pour les vacances
on laisse même pas rentrer pour les
vacances bah oui vous avez bien pourquoi
pas mais le problème c'est c'est
systématiquement le même c'est qu'un
français c'est un expatrié lorsqu'il va
s'installer dans un pays étranger c'est
c'est un expat ses fashion c'est pour
faire rayonner la bonne boulangerie
française regardez cette boulangerie à
san francisco qui vont des croissants ou
ce restaurateur qui au japon mais
derrière les noirs et les arabes c'est
pour la cmu et la caf si si la vessie
chez où les laisse vous ai remarqué bea
d'africains ou un algeria qui va
investir en france il ya le droit c'est
de venir y travailler ont leur vérité il
préférait travailler chez eux je vous
assure un nom mais je par les
multinationales elles tweed accord oui
mais c'est cesser les travailleurs juste
une date à question puisqu'il n'aurait
très peu de temps anette cazzidy la
grève les manifestations vous aurez fait
beaucoup est ce que c'est encore
opérationnels cgem passion ça fait
partie une mythologie de gauche faut
passer par là c'est les combats
et puis alors les manifestations après
on va se plaindre des violences
policières et pour manifester contre les
violences policières on en oublie même
pourquoi ont manifesté au début au
moment avant les violences policières il
vous est pas l'impression que ça tourne
en rond et que ça mène nulle part oh non
pas du tout bois déjà il faudrait
s'interroger des violences policières et
non pas les simplement les condamnés de
se dire pourquoi elles sont là pour nous
mais vous m'avez compris les jeans et
jouit au début j'avais des
revendications et gfc la police bout de
quinze jours on a oublié leurs
revendications parce qu'il n'était plus
là que pour manifester contre les
violences policières je veux dire c'est
qu'il ya tu restes à fred il a bien sûr
c'est qu'avec à tarascon avec vous je
veux dire par là que j'ai l'impression
que c'est toujours pareil c est que et
j'ai l'impression que c'est mou je sais
pas si ça a été efficace à une époque
j'ai l'impression que ça l'est moins
voilà très sincèrement tout à l'heure je
vous parlais de cette grève qui a duré
plus de 60 jours contre la réforme de
cette réunion ne traite pas écouté
aujourd'hui ce que la route la réforme
de le voit est passé non à la réforme de
vous pensez que c'est ça c'est le co
vide qui a empêché de bain je pense que
il ya eu qu'ovide mais la réforme contre
l'assurance chômage où il n'y a pas eu
un seul jour de grève ça n'a pas empêché
de passer et je pense que s'il avait pas
un seul jour de grève contre la réforme
des retraites macron n'a que faire du co
vide c'est un texte on l'envoie à
l'assemblée ça passe ça passe à l'as
donc heureusement qu'il ya eu ces grèves
là après il peut dire 2022 etc mais
c'est défensif tout ça seillier as sahab
défend si ça je suis entièrement
d'accord je vois pas la gauche souvent
aller vers des choses progressiste est
positif avec ce projet des sachants
salsa vous prêcher un convaincu là tu
sûr ça moi je suis profondément
convaincu qu'il faut rompre profondément
avec cette logique de lutter pour rester
simplement haut niveau dans lequel on
était sa demande d je vous ai dit cette
phrase tout à l'heure de trotski où on
est on n'a pas envie de faire d'énormes
sacrifices en fait pour peu de résultats
et la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
encore faire 60 jours de grève juste
pour dire laissez moi comme j'étais
c'est les gens ne veulent plus faire ça
ils sont près par contre à des grèves
offensive typiquement aujourd'hui on est
dans la période qui aurait cru qu'une
entreprise comme leroy merlin dans
laquelle n'a jamais eu grève décathlon
auchan sephora etc vous avez carrefour
vous avez énormément d'entreprises cette
fameuse première ou deuxième ligne peu
importe comment on l'appelle mais qui
étaient là durant la crise du duc au
vide qui a été là durant le confinement
qui a travaillé qui a tenu comme on dit
l'humanité ses promesses et caissières
qu'on a applaudi à la caisse alors
qu'avant on méprise on leur disait
dépêche toi fais vite elle met trop de
temps et au moment de la crise on les a
applaudis à toute cette ligne là qui on
a vendu du rêve on leur a dit vous
inquiétez pas on va prendre en
considération ce que vous faites on a vu
votre pénibilité la pénibilité du
travail il y avait notamment un
éditorialiste que je cite de temps en
main qui s'appelle dominique ce qui est
sûr sur d'autres chaînes dominique seux
il a fait un billet au mois deux mois de
d'avril 2020 où il ce qui s'appelait
virus de classe et disait jamais on n'a
vu autant en fait les antagonismes de
classe et disait cette prime qu'annonce
le gouvernement paraît dérisoire et
c'est bien une revalorisation des
salaires qui va falloir entamer
rapidement après parce que tout le monde
a vu que ces prolétaires ces ouvriers ça
soit chez auchan dans les transports
chez dès l'hiver ou autres sont mal
payés et aujourd'hui plus que jamais il
se mobilise pour l'amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail et de salaire donc
oui la grève ça existe et ça a été
démontré par plusieurs reprises je pense
que peut-être une des erreurs des gilets
jaunes ça a été justement que le samedi
même avec toute la radicalité n'est pas
suffisant parce que s'ils samedi vous
êtes là radical mais que le lundi vous
êtes en train de faire tourner la
machine à économie ça va pas et je pense
que ce qu'il aurait fallu et c'est pas
et je jetterai jamais la faute au gilet
jaune pour conclure là dessus je pense
que le rôle des directions syndicales a
été primordial qu'ils ont préféré regard
d ailleurs parce qu'il voulait pas
participer à la déstabilisation de ce
système là mais que si les directions
syndicales avaient dit les cheminots la
ratp les raffineurs l'énergie etc la
propreté tout le monde avec les gilet
jaune on paralyse le pays on va frapper
la fort on va aller jusqu'au bout et on
va pousser des revendications et autres
je pense qu'on aurait été dans une autre
dans une autre situation que simplement
les cds gilet jaune se battre se battre
tout seul chaque samedi merci à nazim
bllaca d'avoir passé toute cette
émission avec nous merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
la violence peut déstabiliser la société
trop de sécurité de mettre en danger nos
libertés
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française allait aussi critiqué ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si